it would be wrong to assume that Trump's
trials and indictments will only affect
the presidential race I believe that it
will affect down ballot Republicans and
it has the potential depending on how
this all goes over the next six to 18
months to generate an insane amount of
chaos for Republicans trying to get
themselves reelected in November of
2024. if you are a pro-trump Acolyte and
you're trying to get reelected and Trump
really has legal issues and is damaged
in the primary maybe loses it or wins
but then loses to Joe Biden
it could turn off a lot of people from
voting for their local elected official
house or senate for reelection on the
other hand if you take the anti-trump
side as a republican seeking re-election
in 2024 and Trump prevails that could
end up being very damaging to you so
there's a lot of risk here to many in
the Republican party and as we talked
about late last week Republicans are
worried that Trump is going to drag them
down